les gens sont censés batch et et on se
rend compte que finalement personne
c'est un simple comme jeter comme
thunder vous pouvez aisément y en a des
doutes qui a ouvert aussi je veux pas le
dire parce que c'est payant j'ai payé
une fois
normalement je te plains non tu remplis
plein de cases études effectivement
fumeurs pas fumeur ta religion ce que tu
aimes blond pablo nanana mais les films
je n'ai pas le droit voire sexy vanessa
c'est bientôt les gens n'ont par exemple
pas le droit la relation qui dit on n'a
pas le droit mais oui au fait tu me
laisses avoir le culte des nations 3 non
alors que la religion est bien cd dvd
bilingue ou quoi sont les musulmans il
ya décidera crée des souvenirs n'importe
quoi sur mes qualités que pour les 1000
hausse après l'annoncé de renforts à
droite ce défi en mer dans la zone des
10 qui décide tout ça se fait j'ai envie
de choix du peuple choisir ce que tu
veux comme en face des gens il ya marqué
il match à 81 2 996% il n'a pas le droit
90 radio de vancouver c'est beaucoup en
tous les cas
en tout cas on a on a enquêté nous parce
que il semblerait que ces émissions font
appel à le même système que un fameux
site de rencontres oui oui et oui mais
derrière ce site vous le connaissez tous
oui comment ce parti et on a enquêté et
et franchement c'est édifiant comme il
ya certains c'est la grosse tendance du
moment dans nos vies mais aussi à la
télévision la compatibilité amoureuse
des applications et des émissions de
télé propose de trouver votre âme soeur
en étudiant votre profil après marié au
premier regard sur m6 où des
scientifiques calcul au centième près
votre compatibilité amoureuse c'est le
retour d'une autre émission de matches
dit couple parfait saison 3 sur tf6 dès
lundi
dix hommes
femme c'est couple parfait ont été
constitués par un match longtemps
et oui c'est tendance et comme dans
mario premier regard nos candidats sont
des grandes issus de l'amour vont passer
les relations que j'ai eu ça a été
plutôt destructeur j'ai malheureusement
pas de chance en amour aussi un gros
souci c'est que j'ai jamais dit je
t'aime
même ma mère du coup c'est très
compliqué pour moi en jeu deux cent
mille euros quand même s'il arrive à
reconstituer les fameux 10 couple
parfait en restèrent ces émissions se
sont toutes inspirées d'une célèbre
application de rencontre qui permet de
rentrer en contact avec des personnes
qui vous plaisent par un système de
match l'auteur judith duportail dénonce
dans un livre choc les méthodes de
l'application découvre en lisant un
article que nous sommes tous noté
secrètement sur kindle une note de
désirabilité à laquelle nous n'avons pas
accès une note secrète de désirabilité
alors comment est calculé cette note
et surtout croyez-vous en ces fameux
match scientifique dans la vie comme à
la télé allez le mot de la fin on le
laisse aux nouveaux philosophes des dix
couple parfait c'est l'amour tu peux ne
pas l'acheter l'amour ça vaut pas de
5000 euros
l'amour ça vaut
pour moi pour ma part c'est votre tout
l'or du monde alors vous avez vu je lis
plus les portails dans le reportage à la
halle a fait une enquête est vraiment
mission est il vrai enquête il
semblerait franchement que dans ces
sites est donc le même algorithme est
utilisé dans ses émissions
cette volte face est une discrimination
entre les différentes personnes hommes
femmes évidemment mais surtout dans le
niveau de classe sociale et sera donc ça
semble être un vrai dossier
elle va tout vous expliquer c'est
franchement c'est étonnant génial aller
là j'ai eu l'idée de concerts enquêter
sur teen d'heure quand j'ai découvert
qu'on avait une note secrète de
désirabilité du coup je cherche à savoir
comment fonctionne ce système de
notation et je mets la main sur le
brevet de qingdao et dans ce document
est de taille et un système très très
précis de notation donc sur
l'attractivité physique le nombre de
personnes qui vous lie qui balaye à
droite mais pas seulement
on découvre que thunder se réserve la
possibilité de nous évaluer sur aussi
notre intelligence
en étudiant nos messages en voyant le
nombre de mots compliqués qu'on emploie
par les âges en faisant passer un test à
nos messages issus de l'armée américaine
pour qui permet de deviner le niveau
d'éducation d'un locuteur et aussi sur
notre niveau d'études et notre niveau de
revenu honnêtement si c'est vrai mais
c'est vrai je suis moi jamais bossé
c'est épouvantable charles à sa série
chuck ça mais ça me sentais un peu quand
même
oui bah non c'est donc par on dit que
c'est un système américain qui a aidé le
logo rider mois le big band notamment
comme vous dites mais c'est sur les
terrains je me dirais juste que benjamin
m du mans ça fait peur oui oui oui oui
vous souvenez voilà non mais surtout
c'est très sexiste assas temps
maintenant non parce que justement et
calculs il vous met une note selon si
vous êtes une femme par exemple et vous
avez des revenus beaucoup plus élevé oui
vous allez avoir une sale note ans ça
veut dire que ça veut dire qu'on vous
ils veulent pas mettre en relation des
femmes aisées on va dire avec un mec qui
va gagner moins mais ça doit la
réception tout cela a été vérifié en
fait pour appuyer votre propos savez des
points bonus et malus à la même place
directement en fonction de cette une
dotation vous avez vous devez comprendre
que dans bab drib et à ses côtés avec
plusieurs salles et vous êtes vous êtes
mais de la main
voilà dans ce brevet c'est qu'on
découvre que les hommes et les femmes
peuvent être évaluées différemment dans
ce document il ya un exemple très précis
qui est donnée d'un homme qui gagne bien
sa vie et qui a fait de bonnes études
du coup il ya des points bonus et une
femme qui a exactement les mêmes
diplômes exactement la même salaire de
son côté elle a des points malus c'est à
dire qu'on construit un monde où chacun
et avec les beaux et klebold l'émoi chez
avec les moches les pauvres avec les
peaux je voulais aussi avec mon livre un
peu ouais tendre la main aux autres
nanas appui aux mecs aussi en disant bah
ouais en fait voilà un peu ce qui se
passe pour de vrai quoi est-ce que c'est
très bien mais ça paraît choquant mais
quand vous allez à lancer dans des
agences matrimoniales
c'est exactement le même principe on
essaye de mettre des gens qui ont à peu
près le même niveau d'études a eu lieu à
peu près le même niveau d mais le
salaire du niveau ça se fait c'est moins
enclines mais maintenant la plus rare le
dira mais ça s'est toujours fait je suis
même sans la manière dont mais dans la
vraie vie c'est pareil moi je suis
contre tout ça je déteste mais dans la
vraie vie vous aideront contre quand
même ça turbine d'heure vous m'a bien
sûr que non
d'abord j'avais ok mais quand même je
suis content ça non mais dans la vie
c'est pas pareil
les bois d'argent maintenant on va te
n'est pas très cher je suis ne peut pas
laisser dire ça et c'est pas léger non
on est prêts destinés aussi à l'amour
alors c'est délirant ce truc pg là les
vrais mots c'est sexisme discrimination
s'est égaillé la nation c'est vrai nous
sommes dans l'illégalité la plus totale
d'ici c'est ça ces sites doivent être
interdits inoue diatement le
gouvernement je vois si les virer voilà
bien mais je devais rire comme ça vieux
arrêté ou de rabat
tu te la sarre casser les couilles de
leurs droits
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est un super bien sûr les très
honnête quand vous dînez avec quelqu'un
ça m'est déjà arrivé il ya quelqu'un qui
est très beau et très machin mais si
vous voyez en fait que tout d'un coup il
n'a pas la même culture
il fait des trucs avec ses couverts que
vous aimez pas vous sentez que sales
sales fera pas cas culture il y les
manières de parler va dire c'est la
soeur à mach ça c'est pas voter vous
savez très bien que ça le fera pas et
soyons honnêtes un nom jésus se fera
donc ce n'est pas ta culture de façon
milieu sur intranet ça le fera pas c'est
pas ça qui est en jeu c'est vrai on en
face vous laisser même pas parler les
femmes taisez vous on est plein de
filles être sûr d'une heure c'est
absolument pas sexiste et ce que je ne
comprends pas c'est que la cia dont elle
parle on s'en fout à l'inversé de la
star laisse moi juste un an et s'il te
plaît j'aime à dire sa robe on a besoin
d'eux on a besoin de ces sites là ils ne
servent uniquement que pour la galéjade
[Applaudissements]
je suis sur un autre site qui n'est pas
pour ça ça m'a vachement je connais le
nom de votre site
ayen sehatra porter du bleu de bonnes à
prendre chez tous ces crétins et c'est
dommage tu sortais ça parce que oui
c'est sexiste mais ce qu'il faut savoir
rester très dur et ce que dénonce judith
duportail c'est qu'en fait c'est nous
mêmes qui donnons les informations pour
que thunder les conserves
elle a gardé 800 pages elle est là 800
pages de ses échanges avec tous les mecs
avec qui elle a discuté elle pensait
qu'elle avait discuté avec 50 mecs
finalement elle est en ligne parce que
c'était devenu addictif pour elle avec
une liste en mec c'est ce qu'il faut
savoir et à 27 pages dont elle parle qui
ferait trembler kinder site antec qu
elle les mettait un jour sur le web
c'est ce qu'il faut savoir on donne des
informations pour que tin d'heure après
nous évalue alors oui que ce soit
sexistes pas sexiste on y va donc on
évalue la vie
tout à fait